it's seven o'clock this is sky news
breakfast these are our top stories this
morning
[Applause]
coming home from rome celebrations
continue throughout the night after
england go through to their first
euro championship semi-final in 25 years
captain kane led the way with two goals
as three lions knocked out ukraine in
do you emphatic what it's been the
absolute best night that i've had
in at least two years because i've not
really seen anyone
we'll be live in both rome and here
outside wembley this morning before
england return home to play their next
match against denmark bear
on wednesday also this morning reports
that boris johnson will
end mandatory mask wearing when lockdown
ends on the 19th of july
scrap the protocol the new dup leader
calls for action on the brexit border
i'm prepared to give the prime minister
an opportunity now to put right
what was done wrong to northern ireland
under the protocol
a chop and change in the regulations all
uk hairdressers must now learn how to
cut and style
afro hair as standard during their
training
plus cyprus appeals for help to tackle a
huge wildfire described as the worst
in the country's history
good morning we've got sunny spells and
showers today again some of the showers
could be heavy
and thundery i'll bring you more details
through the morning
and of course too we'll take a look at
the morning's papers with the
broadcaster and diamond and the editor
of the sunday express
mick booker
good morning welcome to sky news
breakfast thank you for joining us
england are going to their first euro
championship semi-final in 25 years
after an emphatic victory against
ukraine in rome
two goals from captain harry kane held
the three lines to a
four nil thumping of their opponents
with celebrations and cries of
it's coming home continuing throughout
the night in both italy
and back in england gareth southgate's
men will now play
denmark in front of 60 000 fans at
wembley
on wednesday night for a chance to get
to their first
major final since 1966
our europe crossed one michelle clifford
reports from rome
many had forked out thousands of pounds
to get here and for the england fans
leaving the rome stadium it was money
well spent
celebrating the team's triumph over
ukraine and a place in the semi-finals
[Music]
england were dominant from the start and
after just three and a half minutes
captain harry kane broke through to put
them ahead with his second goal of the
tournament
and that set the tone for the night
within a minute of the restart it was
two nil
harry maguire inch perfect to head home
a free kick the floodgates were open
harry kane heading in his second a
couple of minutes later
number four came up on 62 minutes jordan
henderson with his first ever goal for
england
this time from the corner the demolition
was complete
harry's had a lot of hard time right
but you know what he became good you
know what it's been the
absolute best night that i've had in at
least two years
no words four nil unbelievable last time
we scored four goals
we know there was only not as many fans
as there would be
[Applause]
england fans had been confident from the
start and what they lacked in numbers in
rome they made up for with sheer
enthusiasm
thousands have been prevented from
traveling from the uk to italy because
of covid restrictions
but that didn't stop brits from across
the european union and much further
afield
from making the journey we've flown up
from dubai
we came in yesterday it's a six and a
half hour flight and
yeah it's been amazing we live in
stockholm so it wasn't too bad it was
just basically stockholm to frankfurt
frankfurter here last night i live in
malaga
and we've had a couple of days
sightseeing and now we're obviously
ready for the game
we've come from montpellier in france we
um we're pretty desperate to get here
because we had tickets for
all the games before the pandemic hit
and then so once it hit we lost all
those tickets and this was the only game
we could have possibly gone to
[Applause]
but with the team's success the fans who
had to stay away from italy will now
have their chance to see england play
again
on home turf the next stop for england
when believer they'll take on denmark
for a place in the final and where
they'll be guaranteed the support
of thousands of fans
there will be some sore heads after
england's latest success
taking them a step closer to becoming
european champions
michelle clifford sky news rome
well in a moment we'll look ahead to the
semi-final with charlotte lomas she's
outside wembley stadium but
first let's talk to michelle who's in
rome this morning
michelle the atmosphere here just
watching the game on tv was
awesome what was it like actually being
there
well pretty much the same um there were
worries i think from a lot of people
including the players
including many fans that the atmosphere
in the stadium wouldn't be
quite the same because of course there
weren't so many england fans there
people prevented from traveling from the
uk to italy because of covid
restrictions but we were outside the
stadium
and you could just hear the euphoria
when the final
whistle blew so people absolutely
delighted i don't think many of the fans
thought it'd be a four
uh nil victory it wasn't just a win it
was a resounding
uh win and of course now it means that
england will be playing their next match
at wembley next wednesday against
denmark and that means
many more fans will be able to go and
watch the match
harry kane the england captain last
night tweeted his delight he said
after such a difficult year for so many
people
he was glad and the players were glad to
bring uh so much happiness
to so many people and i have to say
there did seem to be a very good
atmosphere between fans from the two
sides
yesterday you saw ukrainian fans and
england fans
uh talking and mixing during the day and
actually a lot of
ukraine fans when they came out of the
stadium actually said to us that uh
england deserved the win so yeah a lot
of people going home very happy this
morning
obviously there'll be a lot of sore
heads and they will be returning the
fans
not to the uk because they couldn't
travel but returning to places all over
the globe we spoke to people yesterday
who'd flown in from uh america who'd
flown in from dubai and lots of people
who've flown in
right from right across the european
union
okay michelle thanks okay well let's
talk to
charlotte because that is where they're
going to be on wednesday 60
000 fans will be allowed and that's the
ticket to have isn't it charlotte
it certainly is all eyes here now on
wembley where england will take on
denmark in the semi-finals their first
semi-finals in the european championship
for
25 years and the fans here will be ready
to welcome the team as michelle
mentioned there
many fans not allowed to travel to rome
due to
covert restrictions but they'll
certainly be ready
to try and get a ticket here there will
of course still be strict
entry requirements here trying to get a
ticket you'll have to have
proof of a negative covid test
or be fully vaccinated 14 days before
the fixture so it will still be quite
controlled
here but many fans hoping to get a
ticket there'll be more than 60
000 tickets available as wembley
increased
capacity to 75 for the latter stages
of this tournament and this will be the
largest
sporting event here in the uk to take
place
in 15 months so the england fans and the
england team
will be hoping to continue that solid
performance
last night hopefully get them through to
the final which will take place here at
wembley again
on sunday that will be awesome
michelle charlotte thank you so much
well away from the football and next
week boris johnson will spell out where
the covert restrictions
in england will end on the 19th of july
with
signs suggesting the government will go
ahead with lifting most if not
all lockdown measures now with the
health secretary sajid javed keen to
stress that the link between cases and
hospitalizations has been broken by the
vaccine rollout
there are reports that mandatory mask
wearing will be ditched on the 19th
our political correspondent rob powell
has the latest now from westminster the
final sign off
for july the 19th will still be a week
tomorrow on july the 12th that's when
the government will look to see whether
all of their tests have been met
but we should get some sort of
indication of the direction of travel um
in the next
week or so and all signs coming from the
government
is that they're pretty confident about
that july the 19th date
i'm pretty confident about being able to
lift uh most if not all legal
restrictions the new health secretary
sajid javid
writing in today's mail on sunday has
said that england is on track to hit
that date
but he did warn that we are likely to
see a significant increase in cases
but crucially it appears the health
secretary does believe that the vaccine
program
has broken the link between infections
and deaths pointing out that whilst
cases have gone up recently
the numbers of deaths have stayed
relatively
steady now also in a number of the
morning's newspapers reports that
uh mandatory face mask wearing will be
dropped from july the 19th
that boris johnson could be getting
ready to announce that
within the next week number 10 uh saying
that no final decisions have been made
but of course ministers in the past
even on air have said that the aim is to
remove legal restrictions and that will
mean
mandatory face mask wearing uh going um
out the door now the question is whether
that is replaced by guidance and what
type of guidance and where that applies
to
whether people stick to that guidance
and whether that
really allays the fears of some medical
groups that have been speaking out this
weekend
about their worries we should also get
an update in the next week or two on
international travel
the potential for acts in quarantine
from amberlyst
countries so all in all probably 10 days
of relatively positive news that's not
to say there aren't some worrying signs
cases starting to grow quite quickly so
it will test the mettle
of the prime minister to go ahead with
lifting a lot
if not all legal restrictions while
cases
are on the rise especially as boris
johnson is someone that
in the recent past has been accused of
being too eager to get back to normality
we have some breaking news from the
philippines this morning and that is
that a military
plane has crashed and broken up into
flames
in the southern philippines with 92
people on board the army chief
has said that 40 people have been
rescued it's a c-130
hercules aircraft of turboprop
it's from the philippine air force and
according to an air force statement
it had a mishap on landing on the island
of
jolo that statement says rescue efforts
are ongoing pictures
from the scene there are some pictures
um this is according to reuters
saying that they show flames and smoke
pouring from the
wreckage of that plane that c-130
amongst trees
the defense minister of the philippines
has told reuters that the plane was
carrying 92 people
including three pilots and five other
crew members that's according to his
initial reports the defense minister
um and reuters again saying that the
armed forces chief
telling reporters at least 40 people
have been rescued
from that plane and they are now being
treated but the news this morning from
the philippines reuters reporting that a
military plane
a c-130 hercules has crashed on the
island of
jolo 92 people on board the army chief
saying at least
40 have been rescued we'll keep an eye
on that and bring you any news
from the philippines this morning but
let's have a look at some of the other
stories
making the news and cyprus has called
for international help to deal with the
most
severe forest fire in its history local
officials say the blaze has a perimeter
of 25 miles with at least
three villages in its path evacuated
the demolition of the collapsed miami
apartment block
is due to be brought forward to today as
tropical storm elsa heads for florida
the search and rescue mission has been
suspended amid fears that the remaining
parts of the building could be brought
down by the heavy approaching winds
24 people are known to have died in the
collapse 121 are still missing
three people have died following
tropical storm elsa's rampage through
the southern coasts of haiti
and the dominican republic miami's
national hurricane center says the storm
is now approaching cuba
on its way towards the florida straits
at least two people are dead and 20 are
missing after a powerful mudslide
demolished houses
in a town near tokyo on saturday morning
the mudslide happened
in atami southwest of the japanese
capital after a week of heavy rain
caused rivers to swell the japanese
military have been drafted in
to help with the rescue effort
the new leader of the democratic
unionist party says northern ireland
risks losing out on economic
opportunities
because of the brexit border in the
irish sea in his first tv interview
since taking up the post sir jeffrey
donaldson also
said any process for dealing with the
legacy of the troubles
needs to respect victims he told us
senior island correspondent david
blevins
that the prime minister needs to
recognize that the brexit protocol is
destabilizing devolved government
we've heard him recognize that there um
there are difficulties in terms of the
relationship between great britain
and northern ireland but not just in
trading terms the prime minister
also needs to recognize that this
impacts on our constitutional position
i'm prepared always to give people a
second chance and i'm prepared to give
the prime minister
an opportunity now to put right what was
done wrong
to northern ireland under the protocol
but there are those who would say
it's time for the dup to put right the
wrong
of promoting a brexit that was going to
require a border somewhere
is it perhaps time to look at the
positive to promote the benefits of
having
access to the eu market and the gb
market
i believe there are opportunities going
forward but
we can't get to those opportunities
because of these unnecessary barriers
much of our supply chain comes from
great britain
whether you are a consumer buying goods
in a supermarket
or a business relying on component parts
for your manufacturing process we need
to fix that supply chain problem
we need to restore northern ireland
place within the uk
both the market and constitutionally and
if we can do that
then yes we will see the opportunities
that will flow
uh provided we can find practical
solutions
on trade with the eu let's talk for a
moment about
legacy we've seen another two historical
prosecutions
collapse this week how does northern
ireland
draw a line under its difficult past is
there an alternative
to the government's proposal of a
prosecutorial amnesty
i think we need a a process that moves
us from where we are
to where we can finally say well look
we've examined the past
we have given people the opportunity and
to
explore whether there is the prospect of
prosecutions
against those who murdered their loved
ones um and
and then yes we need to move to the next
phase of the peace process so
we need some form of process that
recognizes the suffering
of many the injustice that many feel in
northern i don't think you can
pull a veil over that i don't think you
can ignore that
i think that if we're going to have
healing we need to have recognition and
acknowledgement
and you can see more of that interview
on trevor phillips on sunday this
morning 8
30. trevor's also going to be joined by
the housing secretary robert generic
and labour's shadow chancellor rachel
reeves
let's go back to our top story now in
england reaching the euro 2020
semi-final after thrashing ukraine
four nil in rome let's get the thoughts
now from tony bennett and his family
they actually were at the game last
night
and billy grant who's been to 15 major
tournaments supporting
england billy hang on we're going to
talk to tony and his family first
tony we chatted to you yesterday your
entire family
you were looking forward to it did it
live up to your expectations
oh i mean sorry for my voice
um we had to make uh enough noise for
all the fans
but uh outstanding performance
unbelievable
um and the best england performance we
can ever remember
and uh for once we weren't worried it
was it was it was a good performance and
there was
there was nothing to worry about right
the first goal was what in five
minutes three minutes three years
four minutes by kate who else
yeah um so yeah it was fantastic to see
kane score
and i think the fact that he's now
scored a few goals for england
he's got now got the momentum and the
confidence the motivation to
do even better and hopefully that kind
of give us a little bit of an advantage
to uh
reach the final and uh win it hopefully
yeah
um what did you make of the atmosphere
in the um
in the stadium because when we spoke to
you you guys were saying listen we're
going to be screaming
loud enough for everyone who can't make
it what was it like in the actual
stadium where there lots of england
supporters
it felt like the stadium was completely
full
it was an amazing experience i think
they made up for everybody
it was it was incredible okay what was
your favorite well
let's talk to you amber what was your
favorite moment
of the uh of the match um
my favorite moment i mean i think it
would have to be
either like the first or second goal i
think the first lady because
no one was really expecting it because
the match had just started there were
loads of fans obviously
i mean there was quite a few um quite a
few ukrainian fans
quite through english it was really nice
and a lot of people were chanting
and i saw the ball just go and i didn't
expect it to actually like to score
so when it did i don't think anyone did
so when it did like everyone was
screaming
so loudly and we could see harry came on
the screen
so honestly that had to be my favorite
because like
just it was just that quick and we
scored and it was it was absolutely
amazing and that had to be the best tip
by far
listen it's eight o'clock there thank
you so much for getting up and talking
to us your breakfast does look quite
glorious and the sunshine is this one
was there um was there a big party on
the street
like there were so many units coming
home
and they had their flags and like they
were so many people just
screaming football shots it was so good
like there were people
on the other shoulders and like when we
came out there was this big congregation
like a fans like in like a
big circle and like they were throwing
like drinks in the air and everyone was
screaming they had their flags
and then it was just so loud and then
you walked you could see everyone
screaming like
coming home like it was so good the
england fans were like
absolutely thrilled they were so happy i
mean so we
thank you we made enough noise for a
full stadium
electric oh man that sounds so great
well
thank you so much for chatting to us um
let's chat to billy now he's been to
every match since the 90s haven't you
you obviously couldn't go to the one in
row but you have a ticket for
wednesday don't you i don't have way i
do yeah
the email came through late last night i
know everyone with some tender hooks
after sort of checking that out have we
got our tickets i have to say that i'm
very
very jealous of the better if you go
going to that game in rome because
obviously
going to every tournament 15 tournaments
now i mean going to tournaments is the
thing and they've seen you know that
what we crave when we go to football
i mean i watched a game in a in a
scandinavian bar actually last night we
sort of planned it out we thought if we
could watch the denmark game early on
and then
in england play sweden fingers crossed
afterwards it's going to be a great
night it'll sort of make
up for not being in rome one of my mates
actually a couple of mates were actually
out in rome yesterday they got out there
puns and uh
and peter they got out there so i'm so
jealous of that atmosphere that they've
got but we made
our own atmosphere here back in london
last night in the bars it was great just
being with your mates
that love football that want to see
england are supportive of england
i think that you know there's been a
little bit of moaning about gareth's
tactics and the teams that he's picking
and i've said beforehand
he's the he's the coach he's the manager
he knows what he's doing
he's honestly we just need to get out
the group and then when it comes to it
bang we're just going to smash someone
and we did it last night and the
atmosphere we were with the danes
and us we're all celebrating together
because they all want to play us there
for danes the danish fans so that's just
great so
we've actually got the semi-final that
we want we just have to fingers crossed
actually do the business now
what do you think about southgate's
choices last night
i thought he got it spot on of course
he's got it spot on look you know
i mean we scored after three goals harry
gained a lot of people saying why are
you picking harry kane
he's not very good he they see him in
training all the time they know what
he's like and a player like him you
can't leave him out the side because
once he gets going it's all over
and you know we wanted to score in the
knockout phases he scored
a couple of goals now listen we've got a
couple of games fingers crossed now
you know between now and the final i
think great you know sterling as well
absolutely fantastic like you know even
jordan henderson
comes on you know to shore things up as
it is and puts the ball
in the back of the net listen he's he
knows what he's doing chris powell on
the training
you know a part of his training crew as
well he knows exactly what he's doing
them not listen they've they've watched
what the italians did back in the day
and the germans did back in the day and
they said listen let's do that let's
edge our way to the final and then we'll
just blow people away when we need to
okay step by step um wednesday what do
you think we're gonna
see oh listen i think wednesday
back in wembley of course um so
first of all you're going to see an
absolute listen against germany that
stadium was
was rocking i mean it was properly
rocking so
you know first of all you're going to
see fans uh taking the days off work
so even though it's an 8 o'clock kickoff
i can guarantee you people are going to
be getting you going missing
on wednesday the atmosphere in london is
going to be really tense it's going to
be really vibesy
like you know we're going to get down to
the stadium very very early as we'll
make a lot of noise and then you're
going to see gareth southgate
pick the team that he thinks is right to
take the danes the danes are a very good
side i mean i'm a brigford fan
we got promoted this season and our team
is made up we've got danish manager
thomas frank who's a
top not top bloke you know besotted
podcast we did an interview with him and
he just told us how he'd love to have a
dane
denmark versus england final as as he
says you know we've got loads of danish
players in sort of kind of
um norgard and we've got jensen who come
on all the time for denmark so we know
how good that danish side is and we've
been sort of cheering them on
but on wednesday we're going to stop
cheering on the danes because we have to
cheer on england
and hopefully their path to through this
final is going to finish
at the moment now because there's only
one team that should be going through to
the final but i'm touching wood loads
because i
you know me i don't like to all this uh
superstition business
i've got to keep touching wood to make
sure that we do it i think that england
have shown
we've not an inner goal right we've got
great players we've got great attack
and if we just keep our eye on the ball
we can actually do it but we really need
to be on the ball we can't presume
anything
and i think england fans we've been
through so much we've had
we'd be so close you know 66 1990
like you know russia you know is that
all those games and so much pain but i
think we've learned from that and now
we're actually going to go in
still do the business let's just go and
do the job and i i trust them to do that
i actually feel like cheering for that
little pep talk billy thanks it's not
easy being an england fan is it but
thank you so much
billy and the bennetts thank you
wednesday
good morning we have got plenty of
weather to talk about today
it's a mixture of sunny spells and some
heavy thundery showers
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
the showers today could pop up just like
yesterday pretty much anywhere but the
main focus will be across central
and northern parts of the uk it's a bit
great first thing in the south
the showers around here already and
further north across the north of
scotland also seeing some showery rain
a little bit of brightness in between
but we do have some low cloud
some coastal fog really hugging the
coasts of eastern parts of northern
ireland
northeast england and eastern scotland
in the sunnier spells today we're
looking at 21 to maybe 23 degrees
it will feel warm quite humid in the
sunshine but showers popping up through
the afternoon
and some of those will be quite heavy in
thunder especially through parts of
north wales northern england
ireland northern ireland and into
scotland and these heavier showers will
tend to keep going through the night
tonight
there'll be some clearer spells further
south and fewer showers in the south on
monday but again
could be some more showers to come
further north
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
hello again you're watching sky news
breakfast now today marks the first ever
national
thank you day a day to celebrate the
efforts of the nhs
as well as volunteers and key workers
over the course of the pandemic
events will be taking place across the
country and i'm joined now by
the thank you day ambassador the
musician and chef
levi roots good morning levi thanks so
much for joining me good morning
kimberly thanks for having me i'm
feeling absolutely wonderful morning
today on this blessing this great day
oh it's it's not so sunny but it is a
blessed day indeed
absolutely absolutely and if anyone
deserves a thank you it's the nhs
absolutely and i think you know for us
all i think the nhs deserves it but i
think this is about the community as
well i think
today is a great day for us all to say
thank you to each other
and that's everybody and i think this is
just a fantastic initiative
when i first heard about it i just
thought this is a no-brainer it is
something that i think everybody should
want to get involved in
how did you get involved well i had a
call from a group of people that set
this up you know i think this was a
community initiative i think this is one
that the people wanted to say
thank you to the people like the
shopkeeper down the road you know the
family and friends that's kept us going
throughout this
discovery over the past year and a half
and i had so many people that i wanted
to say thank you to that i was grateful
for i lost my mom i lost my brother
um two you know people closest to my
heart and when that happened you know
there were so many people that i wanted
to say thank you
especially to great great oaks dean
forrest hospice who looked after my mom
before she passed away
and these are the people that i think
that it's really special for me to say
thank you so sorry to
i'm so sorry to hear that was that
during the pandemic yes it during the
pandemic as i said during
the past year and losing two families
and not just me i think we've all
either lost somebody or know somebody
that has lost somebody
so i think that it's just a great time
for us just to just sit back and not
just to say thank you
that we always do but just say with
meaning and in my style
say it with some food which is what i
did later on oh
levi i'm so sorry to hear that it must
have been absolutely terrible to
um just to live through that i'm so
sorry to hear that
um but as you say you are going to say
thank you
through food that's obviously very close
to your heart at
every once i don't like to cook i like
to eat um but tell us how you're going
to do it later
well i've got some help and i've got
some fantastic help from the boys and
girls of the scouts which is absolutely
amazing and from the ncs as well too
so they'll be helping me started to
create my fantastic recipe which is my
own style jerk chicken wings and at
seven o'clock tonight we'll be cooking
keeping the biggest barbecue
the barbie thank you right across the
old country so we can have something to
eat
the greatest thing that i think that
brings people together
is food so we can cook and pass
something over to our neighbors
or if with social distancing bearing in
mind of course
but yes but cook something fantastic and
either share it with somebody
or share a recipe with somebody tonight
that's gonna be absolutely amazing oh it
sounds absolutely fantastic so jerk
chicken and what else
what corn on the cob salads whatever and
i think nowadays
vegan and everything is so you know
accessible to us in our supermarket
i think whether you want burgers or
whether you want sausages or whatever
there is something for you whether
you're a meat eater or whether you're a
vegan
or a vegetarian so get involved in the
culture kitchen
and cook i'll be cooking with the prime
minister a little bit later on so that's
gonna be this
i read that boris johnson is actually
coming to your barbecue right no
actually i'm going to him and to do
something with him so it'd be a great
chance for me to you know to say
thank you and to say thank you to the
england football team because i think
it's
that's made us feel all special special
this morning
and we are grateful for ryan sterling
and for harry kane and for the rest of
the voice
so a really important day today oh levi
we are thankful to you you are our
sunshine today thank you so much and
have a fantastic barbecue
cheers bye bye
let's have a quick look at the weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather sponsored by qatar airways
good morning there will be some bright
or sunny spouse to come today and it
will feel warm quite humid in fact in
the sunshine
but yet again we're going to see a rash
of showers developing across the uk
and ireland and already there's some
pretty heavy showers around parts of
southern england wales
ireland and a few across the north of
scotland make the most of any drier
slots today there are more showers to
come hit and miss as
showers can be and some of them can be
quite heavy and thundery especially
central and northern parts of the uk
perhaps something a little bit better
towards the southeast later on
we do have quite a lot of low cloud and
mist is clinging onto the coast of
northeast england eastern scotland
eastern coast of northern ireland as
well but temperatures
high teens low 20s there are the showers
around as i mentioned they'll start to
fade from the size later but
we'll see more in the north and they'll
continue through the night
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
7 43 now coming up we'll have another
look at the papers with the broadcaster
and diamond and the editor of the sunday
express
booker and who knows i'll maybe get the
names right this hour
see you then
[Music]
well we know we've got to get rid of
coal you know the world
agrees that coal is the most polluting
fossil fuel
we the uk has done great things and more
announcements today
on its coal phase out acceleration but
the uk is a
tiny amount of global emissions with
practically no coal left in its
generation and while we
shut down coal and other european
countries do countries like china
are opening five times as much new coal
as the rest of the world put together
and we know that many economies around
the world are still very very coal
dependent so
i co-created the ppca the powering past
coal alliance with my good friend in
canada
back in 2017 it's been a really
effective way of getting governments
to pledge to come off coal by 2030
um but the challenge is how do you get
into these giant
coal using countries and at the world
business council for sustainable
development our members are drawn from
the most ambitious
global companies who have enormous
supply chains that go
right back into those factories that are
burning coal across the world and so
we'll be working with our members
as part of the ppca to see how we can
use the power of those supply chains the
power of those contracts
to get this coal switch happening faster
companies like apple like google are
very good actually at working with the
local authorities to build renewable
energy plants for example to work out
how to make these changes on the ground
but we haven't been clear
in our view enough about coal we focused
a lot on the switch to renewables
then you often get into a row about is
it okay to use
gas as a transitional fuel in the mix
you know i'm sure you know this but
the way we got off coal in the uk which
happened very rapidly
is by standing up gas standing up
biomass
and investing increasingly in renewables
but many countries say well we can't go
straight to a renewable system you can't
as an energy minister i can tell you you
can't run a grid
of 100 renewables so we don't we want to
use gas and you're telling us we can't
so i think sharpening this message to
say yes we want to transition to a
renewables future
but in the meantime let's put coal
firmly in the gun sites and get rid of
that
in short order you know we look at the
carbon dioxide levels they're the
highest they've been for four and a half
million years we need to make coal
history and we need to do it now
[Applause]
hello or like we say in my language is
relay
i am tonitiv the founder and the ceo of
renewables in africa this picture
changed my whole career
and my whole life our mission is simple
is to bring back power to africa
and our being is to turn the dark
continent that i saw in 2008
into a brighter and prosperous
[Applause]
did you know symptoms of hay fever can
develop at any stage of life
not just in childhood the pollen reports
sponsored by philips connected air
purifiers
it's a rather gray start for some of us
with showers in the south and also for
parts of scotland but the cloud will
start to break up through the day
to reveal a mixture of sunny spells and
further scattered showers
some of which could be heavy and
thundery especially for central and
northern parts still warm rather muggy
in the sunshine
top temperatures will be into the low
20s but certainly a risk of some heavy
and thundery downpours
to watch out for which will reduce the
pollen count
but we are in the peak of grass pollen
season at the moment
the pollen reports sponsored by philips
connected air purifiers
hello again sky news breakfast another
look at the papers now
and diamond and mcbooker are here with
us
again to have another look through hi
again guys um
and let's start with the mail
who is emma isn't it lovely there's so
much good news to celebrate this morning
yeah
um emma rajakanu is the new tennis star
for britain um she was a wild card
she's never played anything like this
before certainly never earned anything
like it before
she was ranked 338 i think in the world
but she got into wimbledon and she beat
the world number 45 yesterday
um just a couple of weeks after
finishing her a-levels she hasn't had
her results yet
and she's got the world is in front of
her now because uh
she's so photogenic i mean just look at
her the papers went crazy and
sue barker said as she was commentating
you know her face is going to be on the
front pages tomorrow
and it was in many of the early editions
so if her family want to go out and buy
souvenirs go for the early editions
um she's on those of course she was
kicked off a bit later by the football
result
but uh she is a rising star she speaks
beautifully she's got a lot to say she's
got a sense of humor and a winning smile
and it just makes you feel good that at
last we've got another rising star in
the world of tennis and particularly
women's tennis
yeah no just fantastic um she's going to
go far
mick what is this mail on sunday what
nice guys can be winners
yeah well apparently now there's a few
stages that the national newspapers go
through during an england uh
following england in a football
tournament when they're doing well we've
just gone past the other excited
terrible pond headline
stage with last night's game we're now
moving into the overly optimistic
uh features uh which look as though
we're already celebrating the fact that
um
the uh players and management have
already won
despite the fact that the finals next
week but we'll overlook that because
we'd like to bask in these things and
as it says katie hind in the mail has
done a nice profile of
gareth southgate and you know just what
a lovely guy he is and
i think we were saying earlier about his
influence on the team and i think a lot
of the pundits have been saying that
but you know he's over the years he's
not been one of the most glamorous of
players and you know he's had his ups
and downs he missed that penalty in 96
but since then
he's slowly you know just built up a
very good management career he's got a
wife and two
kids he's got a lovely sort of mansion
up in harrogate where he lives quietly
he likes to listen to smooth radio he
doesn't get out and about much he
doesn't gamble doesn't drink doesn't
smoke he's an all-around good guy he's a
bit boring but
as it says he's proof that nice guys can
win it just takes them a little bit
longer
so hopefully this time next week we are
still writing these features
and we are just ahead of a big final at
wembley
oh it's going to be fantastic it's going
to be fantastic fingers crossed
okay to the observer now and and uh can
kirsten win
well exactly he's now apparently going
to lay out a very um bold plan
for his financial aspects really um
ambitious plans apparently to make sell
and buy more in britain in other words
another buy britain campaign i'm not
sure that
it's going to work i mean i'm old enough
to remember the 60s by british campaign
which was very successful
and there was another by british
campaign in the 80s bit half-hearted
but we live in a different world now if
you tell people to buy british
what does that mean they shouldn't go
out and buy a nissan car i mean the same
cars are being built in this country
thank goodness with more jobs
available i just think we live in a
different world now and people buy on
merit
and they also buy because they they can
go on the internet and they can find the
best bargain for themselves
and i don't think they'll ever care
whether it's particularly british or not
mick what do you think do you think this
is what labour needs or do you think
even after this people are still going
to say well what does the labour party
stand for under kirstama
well i think this is good because it's
actually a policy and i didn't i
actually couldn't remember
any of their other policies so far and i
think it's a sign i think it's
kierstarman i think uh it's rachel
reeves as well the shadow chancellor
who's
uh who's behind this plan and you know
broadening it it's looking at you know
you british using british suppliers as
well firms between being told to use
british suppliers
uh when making orders and you know she
she's interviewed also in the telegraph
about this and she's talking about how
you know even with passports we
outsource that to
france under the current government and
they're not doing enough and they
they should be doing that and it's it's
a good interview uh
in the telegraph work that she's given
and it just sounds a bit more serious
and something that voters could possibly
get behind because
you know we've seen with nissan last
week um reinvesting in britain with
their new model that
brexit britain does appear though it
still hasn't critics brexit britain does
appear to be
you know if not working too many but
it's it's slowly moving in the right
direction
and it looks as though it is a big
positive so i think labour are right to
get behind the idea that um
that voters do like to be patriotic
about where where people buy and where
we are investing okay let's lighten it
up a bit
um and go to a mix paper the express a
very animated
queen on um what is this page
15. she's at the windsor horse horseshoe
but the straw you've chosen on is
cha yeah i love the way though the quick
the queen at the windsor horse show it's
one of the times you really see her
being her and being interested in what
she's interested in she wasn't looking
at the tennis or the football
and wearing the sort of gear that she
likes to wear and then she changed a bit
later on
when she was being more formal i thought
that was quite interesting but yeah this
one is
what levi roots was talking about um
this is sort of national thank you day
where at five o'clock we're all meant to
raise a cup of tea and toast to
volunteers who've been so brilliant
during the last year
and charles prince charles the prince of
wales
did an interview for hospital radio
because of course hospital radio has
kept people going
always does but particularly has in the
last year he's given an interview a sort
of desert island discs type thing where
he's named his favorite songs
or tunes that get him up um dancing
around
and it's the three degrees he's gone for
now he was always a real
i mean he always loved the three degrees
i think they sang at his one of his big
birthday parties
and he said that his favorite track is
um
giving up giving in by the three degrees
and if he names all the other tracks as
well i mean most of them i don't know
they go well back beyond
the 70s but he did his bit for hospital
radio yesterday
um okay finally fashionista mick uh what
is this
um in the telegraph about high heels
in the ukraine yeah well yesterday the
obviously the big story for
the ukrainians was the football but
there was another big story as well
there was
there was there was a lot of anger about
this picture because there's going to be
a 30 years of independence march by the
army in ukraine
uh from russia and this picture emerged
of the uh some of the women in the
ukrainian army
were have been forced to wear these
heels and now there's been a
big uproar about it about sexism and
misogyny
in the armed forces in the ukraine uh
and to be fair you know we were all
they're talking about high heels not
back heels last night in ukraine
okay and uh it's just interesting
because maybe the maybe the fellas were
playing in those heels because
they looked as though they were the
performance they put in for the
ukrainian side
okay well um we're going to leave it
there that looked absolutely painful
marching in those heels they are not
nice um anna mick it's always such a
pleasure thank you so much have a great
week ahead
lots more still to come on sky news
breakfast
of course england knocked out ukraine
and have a place in the euro 2020 75.